welcome to our first official video on
our new channel called number file all
about different numbers we've decided to
make our first video on a very special
date that's the 11th of November 2011
that's 11 11 11 or if you're American
that's 11 11 11 right so we've come to
nothing on face football stadium which
Brady insisted on in 11 football players
in a team personally I more think of 11
doctor who's but nevermind we've just
come in through entrance 11 if we walk
this way up here to row 11 and I'm going
to sit right here in seat number 11 so
11 11 11 so guess what we're going to
talk about today what 11
yes sir recently we've had a lot of
dates with ones and zeros in them
they're called binary days the like
binary numbers and this is the last
binary day until next century at when
Grady first asked me to talk about the
number eleven especially for this date I
was I was worried I thought well it's a
prime number but I don't know what else
I could talk about and then I realized
there's a way that we used the number
eleven every day all the time we're
going to use a book now you can do this
yourself if you've got a book nearby
grab it and here's my book this is
Johnny Balls second thinks never leave
home without it on the back of the book
there's a barcode and next to the par
code there is an ISBN that's an
international standard book number and
that number it's going to be 13 digits
long or it's going to be 10 digits long
actually I'm not interested in the 13
digit number I want the 10 digit number
does your book have a 10 digit number on
the back now here's something you can do
with that number let's write down my
number here on the back 0 1 4 0 3 1 8 1
9 4 that's the ISBN number fold
jollyball there now the first number
here is actually tells you which country
the book was published the next few
numbers tell you the name of the
publisher the few numbers after that is
the book itself and the very last number
is called a check digit let me show you
something you can do I'm gonna take the
first digit multiply it by 10 okay so 0
times 10 that's quite easy that's a 0
the second digit there I'm going to
times by 9 so 1 times 9 quite easy again
that's 9 the third digit I multiply by 8
that's going to be 4 times 8 that's 32
the next digit I timed by 7 and that's
another easy one for me that's a 0 and
you can keep going and the very last
digit you multiply by 1 so that's gonna
be 4 times 1 that's the number 4 now
what you do is you add these together so
you're going to make a number it's going
to be something like 100 200 300 that
sort of size if I add these numbers
together and I've done this already I've
done this in my head
if you add these numbers together you
will get here the number 121 and this
number is a multiple of 11 and it always
will be if you try this yourself you
will get a multiple of 11 in this case
this was 11 squared 11 times 11 whatever
you get it's going to be a multiple of
11 and they do this on purpose so they
can detect if there's been an error if
you've inputted the book code in wrongly
if you swap two digits over by mistake
it will be able to detect a problem it's
called an error detection code the very
last digit is chosen so that this will
work now the very last digit will be a
number between naught and 10 so for the
first nine digits that's not problem
zero one two three four five the very
last digit the number ten well we don't
have a single digit for a ten so instead
you may see the letter X which is the
Roman numeral for 10 that's used for 10
instead so this part well that could be
anything that they want it to be but
this number is completely engineered to
make this work to make a multiple of 11
if you have one of the 13 digit book
codes they use a slightly different
operation it's actually based on the
number 10 instead from the number 11
okay so this is the view from 11 11 11
the number 11 is used for these error
correction codes but error correction
code that idea is used all over the
place it's used with computers it's used
with mobile phones if you're trying to
send a message and well in transmission
you can lose some of the message so you
want to be able to reconstruct the
message without having to send it all
over again you can do this yourself
again this is with a CD and if you burn
a CD if you hold it up to the light you
can even see where the tracks are and if
you use a a black pen here black marker
pen I could put a dot on this CD and
this would represent something like dirt
or scratch and
this will still play it can compensate
for this missing information well if I
put in a book code we might know there
is a missing five there's something we
can do
in a CD it uses a whole equation with
all sorts of numbers and you can use
that equation to work out which number
is missing and what it is so we've done
this with my CD in my computer right now
I'm going to play you a song a song all
about numbers I thought it would be an
appropriate choice you can hear it does
still fit out slightly more dramatic
than a black marker pen he actually
drilled a hole through the CD so the
data is actually literally missing not
just a black mark we actually took out
the data yet the CD player can
reconstruct it and still play the song
because it will use this error detection
technology this mathematics that
reconstructs the missing information in
fact this hole is about two millimeters
you can go up to about 2.5 if I go even
further I've got one here with three
millimeters our three millimeter hole
this hole is too big let's try it out
I'm going to try and play this as well
you'll notice the difference it's trying
it strains best it doesn't play too much
missing information so 11 was designed
starting point into a world of
mathematics and error correction code
something that is used everywhere that
makes your CD work that makes your
mobile phone works and of course makes
that number on the back of a book work
and and Brady insists that I remind you
yes it is the number of players in a
football team